i'll start good morning to everyone
my name is sharon cochran and i am the
chair of the lakeridge health board
and on behalf of the lakeridge health
and the lakeridge health board
we would like to welcome you to a very
very important celebration
of this new long-term care facility
our home
and it is a home
that has been
a collaborative partnership
with our provincial
municipal
and construction partners
over the last 13 months
and i should begin it it is always
a pleasure to be at a special event
with the premier
doug ford
minister kohanta
the minister of long-term care
minister sirma the minister of
infrastructure
and minister elliot
the minister of health
and we also have our durham mpps
peter beth and falvey
and lauren cole
i would also like to recognize
the leaders from lakeridge health
dr tony stone our chief of staff
and cindy davis our president and ceo
this
new
long-term care facility
benefits
all of the durham region
and it has enabled
health improvements that matter the most
320
long-term care beds
it has enabled connected partnerships
and i think you've already heard me
comment on that
and it has enabled lakeridge health's
journey
to creating
an integrated health care system
one system best health
and i would just like to conclude with
just a huge and i could use the word
huge again thank you to all our partners
this collaboration among all these
partners
has enabled us
to complete
this project on time
and to celebrate the upcoming
opening
so i'm very pleased to turn over to
prima ford
well first of all thank you so much uh
sharon and
and cindy and dr stone as well your
whole team
uh before i begin
i want to say a big thank you to the
entire lake ridge health team
all the heroic nurses the doctors
paramedics personal support workers and
hospital staff who have gone above and
beyond during this pandemic
you showed up day in and day out and for
that we're forever grateful
it's great to be in ajax with minister
calandra minister sirma minister elliott
minister bethan falvey and mpp lorne co
and it's an honor to be joined by mayor
sean collier and cynthia davis president
and ceo of lake ridge health as well as
ceo of infrastructure ontario michael
lindsay
michael all of you are actually
champions
it's hard to believe that when i was
here just over a year and a half ago
this was an empty uh plot of land it's
really incredible what they've built
behind us
seeing a brand new long-term care home
here in such a short time it's truly
amazing from shovels in the ground to
substantial completion it took only 13
months and if you put that into context
folks it took 13 months a typical build
will take
upwards to eight years so again a big
shout out to
all the partners involved this just
shows that when we put our heads
together when we look outside of the box
for new solutions when we say yes to
building ontario we can accomplish great
things
our governments accelerated build pilot
program was designed to get
infrastructure built in record time
by using hospital lands modular
construction and speeding up procurement
we saw we could deliver more long-term
care beds faster
this is the first long-term care home to
be completed under the accelerated build
program
delivering
320 new and much-needed long-term care
beds to durham region
providing vulnerable seniors with a
comfortable place to call home as soon
as march the 31st of this year
i want to put that into context for you
as i said earlier on
between
2011
to 2018
the previous government only built 611
long-term care uh beds built right
across the entire province
less than one bed per home
with this project alone we're adding 320
new modern and comfortable beds
we listened to the call for more
long-term care beds to care for most
vulnerable
and after decades and decades of under
investment from previous governments we
knew we had to take action we knew we
had to get building
we committed 6.4 billion dollars
to build 30 000 new long-term care beds
by 2028
as well as 28 000 upgraded beds across
the province
i'm so proud of the work our government
is doing to answer that call
i want to give a big shout out to our
partners lakeridge health and i got to
give a special shout out to pcl
construction this is an incredible firm
folks you want to get something built on
time they built this in 13 months i
don't know of any other company that
could do it in 13 months had an
opportunity to speak to the front line
construction folks uh they're they're a
great great team there and i again i
just want to thank them and all the
incredible workers i met here today
along with infrastructure ontario real
champions in getting this project across
the finish line
we found bold solutions to build new
homes and this pilot program has shown
that it can work and produce results
i can't wait to see the same results as
we push forward in other rapid build
long-term care homes in mississauga
north york and toronto
they're critical part of our plan to
build ontario
but we can't build this province alone
we all need to work together to get our
seniors off weightless sooner to reduce
gridlock with roads and highways and
expand public transit
our government is saying yes
to all of that
we're saying yes to building ontario i
just want to thank you and god bless the
people of ontario now i'll pass it over
to minister clander
thank you uh thank you so much premier
and thank you all for being here it's uh
obviously it's great to be here today to
celebrate this uh this achievement
as ontario's new minister of long-term
care it is of course an honor to
continue the important work that was
already underway to fix long-term care
across the province of ontario and of
course we have a plan to fix long-term
care and ensure ontario's seniors get
the quality of care they need and
deserve both now
and in the future the plan is built
around three pillars improving staffing
and care strengthening accountability
enforcement and transparency and
building modern safe comfortable homes
for seniors this new home at lakeridge
health hospital will be integrated into
the broader healthcare system in durham
region to ensure residents have access
to the specialized care they need such
as dialysis building more safe
comfortable and modern beds for our
seniors is what ontario needs and it has
needed this for decades
and we are delivering
congratulations once again to lakeridge
health and its partners and your great
work to deliver this much needed home
for the community and with that i will
turn it over to minister cerma thank you
good morning i'm thrilled to join
premier ford minister of long-term care
paul calandra and everyone to see the
progress and occupancy at the
state-of-the-art long-term care home
here in ajax
we know the past two years have been
challenging the pandemic has highlighted
gaps in our system that have been
overlooked for far too long
families want to know their loved ones
are getting the care they deserve
families deserve to sleep well at night
knowing their loved ones are safe
our government is making investments
into long-term care that will bring that
comfort to families
normally it takes eight years to build a
long-term care home in the province of
ontario
through our collective and collaborative
efforts with our partners together we
built this facility in 13 months
when all parties are working together to
achieve the same goal
anything is possible
over the next few years we are investing
6.4 billion dollars into long-term care
the pandemic has shown us that there is
no time to wait
these investments are needed and they
are needed now
i want to recognize michael lindsey ceo
of infrastructure ontario who is here
with us today
he is the lead on the accelerated build
model and has been working tremendously
hard to advance procurement strategies
that are innovative and modern
it is through this innovation that we
are now able to announce projects like
the lakeridge health long-term care home
by cutting red tape and working with our
industry partners we have been able to
apply the accelerated build model to
four new long-term care homes in total
in the gta in addition to lake ridge
health long-term care home i am happy to
share that a total of 1 200 new and
upgraded beds will be created at
trillium health partners speakman site
and humber river hospital north york
campus
building long-term care is a huge
priority for our government but we are
also making other important investments
in durham region
such as expanding and renovating schools
like teresa of calcutta catholic
elementary and lakeside public
elementary to accommodate more child
care spaces
construction of the new grandview
children's treatment center which will
create more treatment spaces and reduce
wait times
building the new meadows north public
elementary school that will support the
families that call the community home
and improving recreational
infrastructure at the ajax community
center and downtown ajax sports campus
as i mentioned these investments are
part of our government's larger plan to
build ontario
together we will continue to lead the
way and build infrastructure that will
make our communities stronger healthier
and more resilient thank you
okay we're ready to take questions we'll
be taking questions first here in person
and if we have time we'll move to the
phones just a reminder it's one question
and one follow-up
hi richard with city 680 how you doing
premiere doing good how are you i'm good
thanks i
certainly noticed a change in
the way you described the pandemic in
the last few days you've talked about
learning to live with the virus you've
talked about returning to life before
covet 19. yet the science table came out
with new modeling this morning that said
cases will rise as the current
restrictions ease and hospitals are
strained and they're going to become
even more strained so my question for
you is
when you talk about learning to live
with the virus does that mean we're
never going to see the type of lockdowns
we've seen the past few months or
what will you do if hospitalizations
become troubling again sir yeah it was
dr moore that said we got to learn uh
learn to live with it and i agree with
them but what we're doing we're putting
more money into the health care system
we've created thirty one hundred new
beds we hired sixty seven hundred
new health care workers another six
thousand are on the way we're building
long-term care facilities rapid builds
like this right across the province
investing billions of dollars we're
putting billions of dollars into new
hospitals across the province so are we
are we ready yeah we're we're ready
we're ready to move forward but we have
to do it cautiously we can't just jump
into it and just open everything up
tomorrow we have to be very very
cautious we have a strong plan uh it's
great news that we're opening up uh you
know moving forward we're opening up on
february 21st and then march the 14th
but again make no mistake about it the
the hospitals uh they're in better shape
but we still see a little uh bit of
absenteeism we're still seeing pressure
we're still getting surgeries back up
and going so we're going to be cautious
uh moving forward but we're going to get
there before i get to my follow-up i
just want to be clear lockdowns we could
still see it it's still a possibility no
that's that's not our goal our goal is
to move forward in a very cautious way
to make sure we don't have to uh have
lockdowns and when we invest in the
health care uh there's one thing i keep
saying for the last four years with all
the other premiers from all the
provinces and territories from all
different political stripes we need the
federal government to pitch in the cht
canadian health transfers folks we're
we're getting 22 percent
out of the 100 percent that we're
investing there's no province no
territory that can sustain uh the the
funding we just can't do it so we need
the federal government to step up and
contribute more than 22 percent we need
ongoing funding from the federal
government because we can't take 78
percent of the burden they take 22
percent of the burden and expect to
continue to grow and fund the health
care system premier i want to ask you
about the trucking uh protest situation
in ottawa i know you put out a statement
yesterday condemning some of those
actions why did it take you till monday
to put that out and what is your message
this morning to the truckers that remain
there well you know my message right
from the beginning of this pandemic when
i when it came to the truckers
i appreciate everything they've done i
appreciate them bringing health supplies
to hospitals putting food on the grocery
shelves but there's there's three things
i can't tolerate
uh desecration of any war memorials or
any memorials zero tolerance for that
you know what what people have to do and
and the flags are waving around is
disgusting in my opinion outside of the
greatest flag in the world the canadian
flag god bless them for waving the
canadian flag but the other thing is
folks there's there's a million people
that live in ottawa you know i i hear
you i hear the protesters
the province here's the protesters the
country hears the protesters now it's
time to let the people in ottawa get
back to their lives these businesses
that have been closed for for you know a
while now the restaurants want to reopen
so
you know i get it i hear you
but we we have to let the people of
ottawa live their lives
hi good morning premiere um our our
colleagues in ottawa have confirmed that
no one from your office nor from the
province reached out to the mayor's
office in ottawa over the weekend to
discuss the situation amir jim watson
received a call from the prime minister
as an example but no call from from you
so what does that that say i mean
you seem to you seem to probably
publicly be telling the truckers to go
home but privately you're not offering
any kind of support to the city of
ottawa well i disagree with that we have
great ministers out right right on the
road right in the field uh mr macleod
said a very uh strong statement and we
have minister uh fullerton there we're
well represented
roberts and goldie gomari i did put a
statement out i put a very strong
statement out yesterday so at any given
time if the mayor needs our support uh
he knows where to contact us he has my
cell number and i put a strong statement
i'm putting a strong statement out today
that people have to you know move on let
the people of ottawa live let the
businesses open up and that's my
statement call okay another question
related to ottawa um i'm sure you're
well appraised of what's happening
within the conservative party uh
currently uh the question for you
obviously because a lot of people have
been mentioning your name as a potential
successor to aaron o'toole if things go
that way do you have any plans
whatsoever to step into the conservative
leadership race if there is a race now
or sometime in the next no i have my
hands full i love being premiere of this
province we're going to build this
province and and i'm going to continue
uh leading this province uh that that's
my job i am just you know 24 7
working on getting us out of this
pandemic i want to unite this province i
i can't stand this divide when i see
this divide in this country and in this
province i want people united and we're
going to get there we're going to get
through this
together we're going to get through it
cautiously but we're going to be uh
united at the end of the day
hi premier matthew bingley global news
uh
you talk about the cautious phased
approach to reopening the province but
with the science table pointing to cases
that are likely going to rise as we see
restrictions ending
and businesses that obviously need
people support how can you both walk the
line of saying get out there and support
businesses when when we don't have the
healthcare capacity at this moment yet
you know you want to it seems like they
seem to fly in the face of each other
well not necessarily you know there's no
secret we have the toughest uh
guidelines in in north america
in north america as everyone's moving
forward we're being cautious we're
making sure we beef up our hospitals
with the staff that are needed and well
overdue with 6 700 health care workers
that we hired another 6 000 coming on on
board we had built 3 100 hospital beds
and building billions and billions
spending billions of dollars uh building
new hospitals building the
infrastructure that's needed but you
know who's an expert on this and showing
strong leadership from day one standing
shoulder to shoulder with me as minister
elliot maybe i'll bring minister elliot
up uh has done an incredible job
minister of health
well thank you premier first of all we
do have capacity in our hospitals and
the science advisory table has basically
indicated that uh it appears that the
peak of omicron has passed
that doesn't mean we're entirely in the
clear of course we still do have high
levels in both our hospitalizations and
intensive care units however that is
starting to decline
this week we've had about three thousand
people admitted to hospital last week it
was over four thousand we have capacity
that's why we're doing things like
releasing directive two somewhat to
allow for some of those procedures that
people have been waiting for for some
time to continue we're opening up
pediatric surgeries cancer screenings uh
making sure that we can let independent
health facilities operate private
hospitals all of those things are
possible because we do have the capacity
that the premium mentioned we have
created uh over 3 100 hospital beds over
5.1 billion dollars 67 new
health care professionals into our
system so that even if the numbers do go
up slightly as we start opening up
the modeling has been done to indicate
that we will still have the capacity to
deal with that increase but also to
start to deal with the people who have
had procedures or surgeries postponed so
we feel that we are ready for whatever
will happen as we move forward i have
one more question for you so don't put
the mask on yet um
when it comes to those surgeries that
you're talking about not all of those
procedures have been given the green
light when when will people who are
waiting and have been waiting for months
and months and months actually get a
definitive answer when when as you
mentioned cases could go back up and and
could delay those case uh those
procedures even further
well we uh
are confident that we have the capacity
to be able to open up gradually and
cautiously in the same way we're opening
up the province gradually unconsciously
we'll do the same thing with the release
of directive two in a tiered approach we
have four different tiers leading to
ultimately opening everything up so that
we can increase those volumes and as you
probably are aware we put 300 million
dollars last july into
extra operating times for evenings and
weekends to allow us to
help serve those people who have been
waiting for a long period of time so
we're doing this very cautiously and
carefully making sure we have capacity
for people have covid and making sure
that we have capacity for people who
need those procedures and surgeries and
with the information that we've received
from the science advisory table and from
dr moore i'm confident we'll be able to
deal with that
minister if you stay there just for one
moment thank you so much adrian gobert
with city news i'll ask a follow-up
question to that uh speaking i was
speaking with with multiple families
last week
one family one gentleman has a sister
who has a cancerous tumor on her kidney
in need of surgery he's a small business
owner he understands the need to reopen
business but he also understands the
need for his sister to be able to get
into a hospital so while bars and
restaurants and other parts of the
economy are open today but his sister's
still waiting for surgery what would you
say to that family
first i would say that i'm very sorry
that people have had to have surgeries
and procedures postponed i know this has
been very difficult for individuals and
their families some have been waiting
for a long period of time
but i would also say
that
although we aren't able to continue with
all of the surgeries and procedures
right now they are all very very
carefully triaged so if someone has a
life-threatening condition they will
still be served right away and so we
have many doctors looking at this to
make sure that if this young lady were
in a life-threatening condition she
would be able to have her surgery right
away so i think it's important to
remember that everything hasn't stopped
completely the most serious cases are
being trans triaged and moved forward as
quickly as possible to make sure that um
their lives will be saved
thank you
thanks just a question for premier ford
premier yourself and your government
you've repeatedly chastised the federal
government when it comes to border
measures
so would it be safe to assume that you
then support the federal government's a
mandate on truckers similar to the
united states that they must be
vaccinated to cross the border so us a
clear answer to ontarians may be may be
beneficial
well i think i've made my statement uh
pretty clear right across the board i i
believe in getting vaccinated you know
i've i've been on the trucker side i've
always supported truckers from day one
but i support vaccinations it's very
simple that's how we've been able to
slowly get out of this and that's how
we're going to continue to slowly get
out of it people may disagree one side
or the other but i'm going to support
getting vaccinated and that that's no
shot against the truckers i think the
world of the truckers have supported
them from day one and appreciate and
very grateful of everything they have
done and continue to do
uh
throughout this pandemic keep in mind i
think it was close to 90 of the truckers
are vaccinated right so i want to i want
to thank all of them
okay we'll move to the phones for
questions now first question please
from karen howlett at the globe and mail
hi karen hi premier my my question my
question is about the upcoming council
of the federation meeting this friday
you and other premiers will be calling
on the federal government to as you
mentioned earlier in your remarks today
to increase
funding under the canada health transfer
there there are advocates who are saying
that any increase in federal funding
should be tied to
national mandatory standards for
long-term care
so here's my question what is your
position on ottawa's plan to introduce
such long-term care standards across the
country well before i pass it over to
the minister of health uh we're strong
believers number one all of us
is health is the jurisdiction of the
province uh in saying that if the
federal government wants to give us
additional funding and saying we want to
allocate it to long-term care we we
welcome that but really for decades and
then this is decades it's not this
government it's that this government the
previous government
where they're pitching in 22
we've been preaching this for four years
so we got to make a move on this and the
federal government has to pitch in we've
spent billions and billions if all tens
of billions of dollars
throughout this pandemic and yes they've
supported us on one time funding one
time funding doesn't cut it we need
continuous funding uh all the way
through for for many years to come if we
want to sustain the increase of uh money
we're spending in health care so i'll
pass it over to the the minister of
health
yes health care is the responsibility of
the province and as the premier
indicated if the federal government
wants to give us some money for
long-term care well absolutely we will
take it but the primary problem is the
canada health transfer amount is too low
at 22 percent it doesn't cover the
increase in costs that we're sustaining
in health care and as the health care
budget increases of course that means
other important parts of the what the
government has jurisdiction over
education infrastructure everything else
we won't be able to invest those dollars
so what we need in health is sustainable
funding through the federal government
increase it from 22 percent far above
what it is right now because among other
things we're having great medical
discoveries great innovations great new
medications to deal with uh
rare diseases things like that our
health care costs our drug costs our
building costs everything's going up so
we're appealing to the federal
government to uh to help us so that we
can have a strong healthy health budget
as well as the rest of the items in our
provincial budget follow-up and this is
the last so as a follow-up would would
the province of ontario work
cooperatively with the federal
government in
introducing national mandatory long-term
care standards well we've been working
cooperatively uh right from day one from
when i first got elected we were in
conversations with the federal
government and it just seems to continue
to go year after year after year and
you're kicking the can down down the
road that doesn't cut it
we're all united we have a strong strong
group of premiers all different
political stripes but we're all united
on making sure that the federal
government pays their fair share it's as
simple as that
and uh we're
leading the way in
new builds you know our goal again is 30
000 beds uh
and by 2028 we're well on our way
uh we're well on our way to making sure
that that we continue to build hospitals
as well
we've had more builds than than
ever in the history of ontario that i
can remember
right across the board but we can't do
it alone we need
the canadian health transfers to
increase
drastically and consistently ongoing
sustainable funding for the people of
ontario thanks everyone and i just i
gotta give a personal shout out i have
one person in the ford family that's
non-political that's my brother randy
it's his birthday today so he's the
smartest of the the group because he's
not involved in politics anyways happy
birthday randy all the best thanks
everyone
you